this is internal design discussion about
future wolf language features there's a
fairly exploratory discussion about
something we are just have just having
to confront it has to do with timed
parametrized objects so let's talk about
the particular thing we've run into so
we have this way of representing flight
data that is data about airplanes flying
over the US etc and what happens is will
have a geo path
well the question is how to represent a
plane flying on a path so for example
when we have a geo position let's see if
I say if I ask for ISS right and I say
what is the geo position of the ISS
somewhat bizarrely
I'm not sure this is quite right that
geo position will be given hopefully as
a four-element geo position where that
is the lat/long altitude and meters
presumably and time as an absolute time
specification that right yes in GMT and
the GMT time zone exactly and okay and
that isn't a date object because and
what would happen if I put a date object
in there oops
as I converted okay so it knows so if I
for example if I put in now here what I
will get out okay fine
okay so it's canonical form is a is has
an absolute time there okay so the thing
we now talked about is a geo path
now geo path normally would be a list of
Geo points but the issue is how do we
also represent essentially a I mean the
the alternative well so I don't
understand why we can't just use geo
path with geo positions that have time
markers in them why doesn't that
represent I mean isn't that if it isn't
information that we want to attach to
each point like velocity Direction
vectors and stuff I see I see I see I
see I see I see so so in a sense this is
a decorated geo position at some level
yes but it's not it's more like a field
now rather than a position well except
that it's a field where we only have
data about specific points by the way
did Roger join us he's wrapping
something a little bit so your path is
is the D equivalent of line so it's it's
a primitive and its main purpose is
graphical okay so what do you have what
would you consider to be I mean a field
though how do we represent a field right
now it's essentially an interpolating
function of some kind exactly yes
so I think for this purpose perhaps an
object called geo trajectory or
something like that which is trying to
eat times and return the information it
has but it's some sort of field
living on a line rather than a field
that lives on homes any dimension okay
so let's let's go mathy here so I mean
we are we basically talking fiber
bundles or something here is this is
there a base space and a you know life
inside the fiber type thing almost it's
like an embedding we're embedding a line
on three dimensional space yeah but I
understand but the line is one thing but
we also have other attributes okay so
the question is
is you know the fuel usage of the plane
right which is something which is not
part of any aspect of the line is that
something that we want to be able to
attach to so in other words look what we
have right now is a time series but what
you're also saying is that there is in a
sense of geo trajectory sit maybe
there's a Geo trajectory series or maybe
there isn't maybe all it is is a time
series in which the in which the the
positions are geo points yes that's true
then we enter the discussion of how do
we interpolate intermediate new
positions quite and I mean there's some
purposes for which okay so there's a
difference between a and this is
relevant to the spatial statistics and
so on there's a difference you know
there's a difference between a point
cloud that doesn't have the you know
derivative and vector information and
well I mean okay so let's let's imagine
that we've got a wind field which is
measured at discrete points but where we
imagine that there is a an overall
vector field that exists right I mean
again we're going to have so we don't
have a good representation how would we
represent the wind field right now how
would we can we interpolate the vector
field we can can't we know it's like the
result of generation data we would give
an array of values and you're
responsible for dealing with those
values I see so so one example of this
will be clear elevation data if you ask
what is the geo elevation at a so if you
ask for a very specific point yeah right
it will interpolate is that correct
exactly okay so it's its own business to
interpolate so if I say wind vector data
and I say here it will hopefully
interpolate
interesting yes so the question is how
do we represent many of these for
example in the elevation data you can
give a region and then you gotta write
exactly or with a third argument of Geo
position to get a geo position with with
positions containing a third argument
but of course that's very particular of
elevations because they fit very nicely
into a position sorry if you came three
hours later on the second argument the
second argument is a type of elevation
so so the in this cases will be
automatic or automatic and then the
third argument is there is the
representation of it and you say geo
position I think it works both with
string and then you get the Geo position
with the elevation there in metres
composition acoustics and numbers okay
so what you're saying is okay so what
would happen with the wind in this case
if I say wind vector data yes that's
what I'm saying we don't have a good
representation for it yet because the
special thing of the elevation is that
they have a natural third argument in
geo position but there is no natural
argument therefore for a vector field so
we need some sort of je or interpolating
function object or something like that I
have discussed this with Roger example
Roger here now yeah I mean that's an
interesting idea a Geo interpolation
that could operate on any where I mean
it's it's sort of like time series
though I mean it's it's an analog of
time series isn't it I mean time series
will give you something where you give
it a bunch of discrete points where it's
no I think that's a is something in mind
that faves like well it's true that time
series does interpolate but time series
can operate through on things you know
are you gonna have this behave like a
function or like time series because
time series makes approximation
otherwise you wouldn't have all these
closure operations today I'm saying if
you're okay if you have a time series
and you applied a function sign on that
in principle that should apply to every
single point in time but it doesn't it
only applies to the points that you have
given and then interpolates between
those that's obviously I see what you're
saying so it's obviously you know false
but it's good enough for for the kinds
of operations that you do on time series
well wait a second waiting so you're
saying the application of a function
commutes with C this is complicated
because let's say I did a moving average
on the time series okay and it's an
irregularly spaced time series and let's
say I'm yes I'm I've got some kind of
window where I'm combining points in the
time series but it's irregularly spaced
that operation does not necessarily
commute with the you know with the time
series interpolation if they're making
sense so that your sign example taking
the sign of the value commutes with
doing the interpolation doesn't it no no
I mean so if you have because let's say
did you use piecewise linear
interpolation yep okay so that means
that you have a straight line you know
between two time points yeah okay
okay if you map those corner points
opening and draw a new straight line
that's not what would happen if you
mapped every point in between right you
know which side so what are you saying
you're saying what we're doing in time
series is we are I mean there are
certain closure properties that you can
establish based on what we're doing is
that true or is that it's all sort of a
level of model that we that we operate
on there and we decided that this is an
adequate model you know it's still way
better than the raw data values yes I
understand
okay so the our log of that for geo
interpolation is what's happening in geo
elevation here is we are asking for a
very specific point and it is doing some
kind of interpolation I don't even know
what to find that geo elevation what
kind of interpolation is it doing
it's quite simple it's um something
linear with nearing that nearer nearest
neighbors okay I think the advantage of
having geo interpolation is we can
include those things that people are
used to in jail like nearest neighbors
and creaking no and I you know other
sort of common and you know useful
things there
so then what this would look like is
like if it's called interpolation it
shouldn't be called that then it should
be something else right because it mean
interpolation produces an interpolating
function which doesn't have this
property that it you know that you can
combine them it it will do the
interpolation for you just fine but you
can't add them together I see as I see
time series is a um I search you're
saying I mean time series you can add to
time series and it will just work yeah I
mean this is really more like geo field
but that's a horrifying name from
spatial statistics I mean that's what
what Jose wanted wasn't you know to
support the whole set of things we do
for time series for Jo there will be a
tall order for anybody to do we're
building something and we will build
something when we come to fields right
now we're working on stochastic geometry
or points where we need spatial data
just as we have temporal data because
otherwise you can't even operate on them
right how is this relating to the the
time series and back-testing stuff that
is it's not related to that that's
another feature for time series there's
no back testing for geo fields
I think yet let's think about that for a
second I mean for fields in general
oh come on Steven yes you can invent
something but it's
I think that we have a Jose's point is
really valid I think that there should
be but the question is what what level
of design I think that there can be
something that behaves as a very user
friendly interpolating function that
will have a different set of and if she
actually shouldn't even be called
interpolation because it doesn't do
interpolations any of these things that
are nearest creaking and so on do not do
interpolation actually they do
approximations what is an analogous
thing I mean we have functions like
piecewise that sort of give you values
based on whatever we have time series
what else do we have that's like that
those are very different creatures they
are very different creatures but I mean
that they are in W and B spline
functions yeah but those are all
functions as opposed to something like
time series which I mean time series if
I'm not mistaken has
so if I do a sub Bali with time series
do I get what I think I'm gonna get yes
okay so it does act as a function at
that level but it also has the feature
that if I just say time series squared
for example then and now I do that so
this will be your to your point about
how yes
um it would be very nice if you can do
that with this geo object and then we
fitted your positions
and we get back I mean you have a lot of
development to do there if you're gonna
build that sorry which which thing so
Richard just say about by the way we
have a question from our livestream
asking what does wind vector data mean
and this expected to see a bearing and a
speed know we have these are these are
the vector coordinates of the wind so
just for my understanding if I wanted to
turn these into a a bearing and a speed
how would I do that
we have wind direction we have we have
wind separated properties what would
happen if I did that hopeless why you
pick the wrong thing oh that doesn't
help ah fascinating doesn't give an
answer how come that arctan doesn't
evaluate interesting I think it should
you yeah I would think so I mean so if I
say so it's okay so if that's right and
by the way if that is right we should
document this and wind vector data
documentation that you can just say two
polar coordinates so this should give
the speed and the direction correct yes
but we have wind direction data and we
the speed data separately oh okay fine
okay
fair enough
fine um okay that's the answer to that
but notice that okay so now what you're
proposing here can I say also what the
the other thing that I thought was
related to what we're talking about in
this meeting but I guess is not related
is my long interest in having and maybe
this is insanely unrelated okay
my long interest in having a version of
plot that can have things like a point
whose position is time dependent and
being able to have some kind of
rendering capability where you know the
thing can actually render if one wants
it to as an animation is that insanely
unrelated what it thinks so and I'm not
sure that that would still then be
actually actually what I really want is
something which is more like key framing
where I could have a point where I'm
giving it
yeah where really what I've got is a
time series right if I say point of time
series blah blah blah that I can say
something like animate point of time
series and have it do the right thing I
eventually then I want graphics
primitives that's sort of symbolically
represent just like sound note has this
capability for symbolically representing
different parts of a the sorry for for
you know sound note sound symbolically
represents different parts of a of a you
know you know what it does and it would
be very nice to be able to do that for
animated graphics primitives to I mean
Roger is that whose roadmap is listen if
anybody right now
I you know everything that has to do
with graphics rendering has to be in the
front and sooner or later you know
because ultimately I think that that I
think I mean I don't think that our
dynamic is strong enough to do this is I
think that there's you know we need to
reorganize the graphics yeah it can
actually do it at the correct speed but
I don't want to bring it up here because
I don't want to discuss it with you
until I have something you know because
I don't want you know I think that we
can build nice animation languages that
are very usable anyways by then
generating the videos that you want to
see for instance
and I can have all the key framing and
synchronicity and all kinds of things um
that you want it won't solve everything
but it will solve you know good you know
the answer to my question is it's on
your roadmap to reorganize the graphics
is a big task no I am aware I'm aware I
mean look we've talked about this object
based graphics etc etcetera etcetera
etcetera etcetera for a really long time
and you know it's a different some
aspects of this in a separate discussion
I think what has happened in the is
there any relevance of the world of
system modeler and so on to all of that
well I mean system modeler can be a
source of dynamic behaviors now system
auditor also has built-in when you model
mechanical systems not system model
Amadas way more than mechanical systems
but form for 3d mechanical systems in
particular it can auto generate
animations you know the the way that
that's ultimately rendered is actually a
subsystem written on top of something
called openscenegraph which is the thing
that gives you
the ability to move just the right
points and not try to rediscover where
there might be dynamics and what stick
libel and what's not ya know who God all
that and then you can get there correct
speed that's what the I mean in
principle one could think about taking
the existing symbolic graphics language
and through a compilation step and a
dependency analysis figuring out what
has to be considered tickler ball etc
etcetera etcetera yes
yes but but I think that as a user you
know as a developer and/or user of it
you want to be able to plug in at the
right point and have that change and not
there be of an undetermined complexity
process in between which is what slows
things down sure I agree I mean it
depends look the dependency tracking if
the dependency tracking is good enough
then you can just think of the symbolic
level and just put things in that are
dependent in various ways and the
dependency tracking will just take care
of it
and hopefully it's possible for us to do
that but okay fair enough um by the way
I think it was this system model of
dependency that caused us to want to
have multi in this meeting and I think
if that if we're not gonna discuss that
here multi could probably leave unless
there's another reason for into relevant
to this um anybody know
fair enough okay terrific
um the someone
from the livestream is pointing out that
this will be a more realistic syntax for
yes that is correct that's a more
realistic syntax for what I was talking
about before
that's an interesting form that T comma
time series really what you want is P
you know because that needs to be the
points the coordinates
you know P doesn't take times right it
takes points
what do you mean I'm sorry I didn't know
this thing here yeah
yes well it depends if the time series
has points in it then you could imagine
this working
right in other words that D this isn't
quite right I agree this is not quite
right you could have point of X of T T
in the first argument yes but then how
does it know how the binding to the time
series works it won't so you need those
no this isn't right
what what is the T look the fact that
this is called T is confusing this
should be P is a time series right just
like we say you know P is a region or
something yeah that's interesting I
agree that's interesting so what is that
time series of three is that a XY pair
no I'm saying that what this is what's
in here is a time series that has the
form you know let's say zero one two
point three seconds
0.3 seconds I'm getting the braces long
yeah that's fine so right so you get
what I'm saying
so that that's like 0.3 seconds but so
the values of the time series are XY
pairs that is correct yes right and so
what that's doing is it's feeding what
that would be doing I mean right now
animate rather boringly just has um you
know you menu max to you there right
here it's taking on discrete values but
this is saying have it over the course
of time scan through a time series
you
that's interesting I mean that would be
a
way to do it um I mean I'm not sure that
that quite is as good as I mean well I
think this gets into the question I mean
that's interesting I'm going to keep a
note of that all right but I don't know
whether that's relevant to what we're
well it is sort of relevant let's go
back again to the question of the Geo
field okay so the issue is we want a
thing like time series that represents a
position might be a Geo position might
be some other kind of position what
would it be call is there a name for
this in the spatial statistics business
I mean time series doesn't really have
anything to do with time except that we
recognize them in other words if we gave
like in this case there's really nothing
about time in these 15 no no not really
you know but that's the most common case
and it has behaviors for many of the
filters and so on day what's called
causal they depend on history and not on
the future that kind of thing but in
what sense is time series really like an
interpolating function like a general
you know parameter goes to value one
dimensional interpolating function I
mean it it uses that there's just one
piece of it it lets just purely for
evaluation purposes
but all the operations that we provide
for you to be able to transform them in
rich ways or things that have is not
interpolating function and that's the
bulk of it so it's in it's not a of
people hijacking time series and using
it for things that have nothing to do
with time what do they not think of
doing that
you can be we try this for some time I
did not make things it didn't really
work why not don't remember the details
I mean you can if it's something that's
time like it should work if it's not
time like you know there's basically a
one real notion of time it's the real
line it doesn't have yeah I understand
so thermodynamic data would be an
example something where there is
something to interpolate right right
this is some how does this relate to
anything I mean let's just saying there
are discrete values you know the phase
diagram for water or something is well I
think that one has some various
functional forms but in general one can
imagine okay so let us again let's loop
back to what we're talking about here so
interpolating function
is it obvious that interpolating
function squad shouldn't just work
I mean once you have I was going to say
this earlier once you have applied a
function to it there's nothing the
system that ever do on its own so if
this would evil a to something that's
the only sensible thing that could do
good work it's not clear of what exactly
it would do if you squared just does it
square the dependent independent what
happens if you have derivatives but but
square root of this is a dead object
what do you mean by dead I mean in other
words nothing you can do is it a little
bit in front of all do something with it
also do you remove the square root again
well no what about this case this case
works you can square and you could take
square root if she wants it to yes but
you cannot do this resonating function
this is my point
no but not at this time but it what if
we allowed the possibility of saying an
operation on an interpolating function
is is taken to be an operation on it's
dependent variables like when the one
side this is true but then what about
you have specified the derivative so you
also square the derivative no that's not
I could you use clear yeah no no I
understand I understand so the problem
is if the interpolating function
contains but I mean the same will be
true if you just have the things in a
list right you'd be saying the first
element I want to square the second
element I want to take two times it
because their derivative or something
and your point is how would we specify
that but that's gonna come up whether or
not we call this interpolating function
whether we call it geofield or anything
else well maybe it isn't gonna come up
there in that case because you're
assuming no no it is gonna come up let's
take the wind direction and bearing
you're gonna want to do different things
if you apply an operation to those
you're going to want to do different
things for the dirt for the speed and
the the sorry that the speed in bearing
or making sense
I think the operating function is
modeled after function itself and we
cannot do we not have arithmetic for
functions yeah
function is dead object pretty much I
mean argument applies here function
could also do something yeah I think
function could do all kinds of things
but it doesn't it's David yeah it's just
a container right
the one thing that goes inside so
derivative is a strange creature that
takes eats functions right right yes yes
because you can take one but if you want
to do something with two functions like
adding two pure functions you know we
made the decision to not do that right
I mean and frankly the things like
through that do do that have been of
distinctly minority interest for the
last three decades well I I don't know
you end up using it like I always want
vector rules and we don't have it I used
through all the time
what is vector rules what would that be
you know I give for the components but I
wanted among the lists so I'm one I'm
sorry I give it between lists but I
wanted you know rule doesn't doesn't
recognize vector arguments properly so
you'd need to do it on on all the
elements in releases so sorry I just
think about straight no yes thread not
true
yeah through this I yes thread is well
used through is extremely minority
through is ahead you know the only way
to write things in modern mathematics
yeah like you have two functions F and G
functions in the in the mathematical
sense and you have f3 and apply a to h2
x yeah true and this is what we would
have to do with opera if we had
operators
yeah no I know I mean through was
intended look 30 years ago through is
intended to be something of significance
because we thought things like this this
operator the this kind of abstraction to
operators will be common it's turned out
it's still not common I think one day it
will be and we'll be happy we have this
function hopefully it's designed
correctly okay but in a case that the
point here um we have a question from
the live stream would a squared and
tabulating function with linear
interpolation be linear again or
second-order interpolation
yes those are all questions that come up
you know and if you do something that's
not even polynomial right the square
root or it is sinusoid or something like
that and and you're out of luck yes okay
the same argument applies to tenancies
yeah I just said that before right okay
so the issue is okay so one question is
we there may be some specialization if
okay if we are talking about geo only so
let's imagine we're talking about a Geo
value field okay
just for the sake of having a name that
we're talking about right the argument
of geo value field would be presumably
some kind of thing that could would geo
value field be like geo elevation data
where it returns a quantity array but
what does geo elevation geo elevation
data returns no no but but the availa
field will be a container it would be
something that is returned by other
functions in particular generation data
could return a new value field that eats
your positions and returns their
corresponding elevations right so
fundamentally this would be something
like something with a form geo position
arrow I want to say this sorry I
understand
but the reason that this is gonna be
what you're gonna want is all these
things find me the nearest points to dis
find me and modify in this region only
you know do a moving map across the
field to do it it's kind of filter
operation there's a large number of
things that you want to have happen on
it
that's what's expensive not that
building the container it's all the
operations
it's like piecewise looks like just
piecewise but you know we have a hundred
different solvers in the system that
makes that just work sure okay so all
that's where all the work is right but
but so what you're saying is that we
potentially have I mean what this thing
would natively eat is geo position value
things like this right yes it's
effectively that what we put in their
first argument of the govt spunk shion's
okay so geo value geo region value plots
by the way notice that with the
statement you just made those could be
extended geo regions on the left hand
side you think exactly okay so this is
can they be curves to theoretically I
don't know that it I don't remember what
it does with curves but like geo region
value plot most definitely works with
single point geo positions sorry how do
we represent a custom region custom Jo
region can we do that with the region
formalism you can has a polygon what's
your thing so it would then be a polygon
of those geo positions right can it be a
region defined by how do you get okay
naive question how do I get a region out
of a polygon it is a region so regular
poly it's noise
arguments on the CHEO positions you
but those are those are not graphics
primitives they are not so if I do this
and I say area I'll get the area of a
pentacle you can also can't do graphics
of polygon with geo positions can you no
I'm just saying it's still a polygon the
head of it is still pretty good well but
you guys did that you know
wait I mean if I say look if I say
something like I think it works of
course the scenes a simple polygon of
your position by try this but it's not
by design because it will be wrong okay
so let's say geo position of these right
and then why is this taking forever
come on what's it doing oh my gosh okay
lovely and now if I say Geographics of
polygons of that okay
so what's wrong with this nothing I
think the discussion is what it's where
the East is in Tripoli quote a pretty
good the meaning of polygon in region
world the dividend and mean from polygon
here yes told what you mean you mean
tree a defect clay or what what do you
mean it Geographic is does a processing
to actually remove this your position
there and pass a pollen was in
Scandinavia as well am I wrong sorry
that's just a general knowledge question
Roger will probably no really
so Nordic countries includes Finland but
Scandinavia's right okay thank you okay
in any case sorry returning to this um
so what do you mean that the question of
what a polygon is you're talking about
the you know curved space or what no no
it's much more in the sense that you can
program
a check in the language like you can for
a breach in queue around and checking
something in region but buddy going with
your position is not a region so one
could argue pretty good right like that
marry a computation wouldn't well so if
I say geo area of polygons of percent 22
it's fine
right but area without the Geo won't
work
right that's a roller in in unpleasant
error message for that case by the way I
think it should say something more
specific to geo Brett that's I think
who's that for
is that for the regions people geometry
people yes okay
small circular or the geo people since
they don't know an unpleasant message I
mean it should say it's a geo that
you've got to use geo functions to deal
with geo areas that's a we much more
useful to say use geo area here which we
are which we perfectly well know you
need so who could deal with that is that
something has to be some kind of valued
thing or is that is that a I mean that's
really the area function that has to
notice that well I mean but I don't know
that area doesn't know that to some
extent areas probably just checking for
is this a valid region okay but then
well look okay somebody can look at that
code path and then the valid is it a
valid region it does geo stuff give you
things which are regions or not so sorry
I didn't hear that would you said no or
yes no it doesn't okay fine so in that
case it can error out at the region
generating stage
anyway that's not that subject here our
subject here although is there somebody
is there somebody from project
management in this meeting yes Sushma is
here
perhaps you could could can you note
that and try and get something done with
that okay thanks
okay
so let's see so we're going back here to
the question of can we define a Geo
value field
you
it's kind of unfortunate gio region
value plot what are the our logs of geo
region value plots yeah okay
okay fine so this is a Geo value field
and that would be its it's basic that
the way it's given inputs is this now
presumably there could also be a
function that says you know somebody
solved the PDE so what happens if
somebody solves a PDE over a Geo region
what happens right now with that do we
have a way to deal with that you cannot
even write it down no you have to
convert it to an actual region okay so
walk me through
I mean Jo evolved as sort of a graphics
hack and it's sort of steadily climbing
itself out of that well good for it I
mean but it's very complicated because
it's got geoids and I know Steven I know
but I'm just saying and they happen in
parallel these things so right although
to be fair to geo it's really got two
different branches it's got the graphics
part and it's got the geodesy part yes
which has um but so okay so let's walk
through this for a minute but even the
interpolating function it could be you
know very aware of you know if you have
a you know to interpolate correctly on a
geoid so to speak you know it could know
about all the things it needs to know
about we in an actual interpolation
interpolation the function yeah yeah
because we know what projections you're
using we know what jacobians we know
compensations for transformations okay
so wait a minute so so just to UM what
you're saying is that interpolation
right now could take if I do an
interpolation okay so first question if
I do an interpolation that involves x
does it work in any useful way no okay
should it I don't think so because it's
gonna have a whole world of syntax and
notations and special cases and because
what of time but I mean if I was times
and dates because their calendars their
holiday
there are all kinds of things that you I
see what you're saying so interpolation
of the pure real function of dates is
not you claim all that useful in other
words there is a notion of a base space
so to speak here that is purely the time
axis you know the one dimensional real
number time axis
oh sure that's that's straight forward
but you know if it's gonna be a user
convenient kind of function you need all
that okay so your point is that
interpolation of essentially real time
vet you know variable mapping to
continuous value is not the case that
you're interested in you're interested
in things like you know in um what am I
saying and in in in kind of well what
will be the case interpolation ignoring
weekends or something you know anything
you're talking about yes yeah how does
this price change ignoring weekends
because it's not traded then right so
how do we represent things like that how
should we represent things like that
but isn't that time serious business lee
what time series yes but it's a
substantial subsystem that deals with
time time series deal with weekends yeah
it deals with calendars how there's no
business days they they you know so for
instance if you have stock data okay
weekends are counted as if they don't
exist
I'm saying cuz otherwise you will get
gaps in your data your price there would
be no that would emit missing data every
weekend no accident I understand so you
riveted wrong if you if you go across
assuming it wasn't traded at weekends
and you're computing the derivative of
the stock price you're saying that that
derivative needs to know that the the
you know the Delta Y by Delta X the
Delta X is only 1 between Friday and
Monday
rather than being 3 is that correct yes
yes so therefore a day they want
business calendars you know from you
know when you do do those right but so
how do we do that in the case of Time
series so do we have a calendar do we
have that notion in in time series yeah
it has kind of typing analytical
interruptions reason that's a it's not a
small subsist on their phone you've
given me a really good argument for why
we want ATO value field but we don't
want a general vector field for general
vector fields that are really a mapping
of you know reals two reals use
interpolating function does that make
sense yes but that if we want to do this
geo value field okay let's go back to
our aeroplane okay so the aeroplane is
actually not a geo value field the
airplane is on a particular trajectory
and we are merely trying to record for
that trajectory right we're merely
trying to record the you know the you
know like the plane if there's wind
right the planes nose will not be
pointed in the direction the plane is
going in for example and they're making
sense now I don't think that that's not
actually what you know now I'm now I'm
totally confused I should remember this
from flying small airplanes but the
heading of a plane right when you
plotted out the heading is the actual
direction you're going not the direction
of the nose of the plane is no and I'm
totally confused because the compass in
the plane must be showing the direction
the plane's nose is pointed not the
vector not the velocity vector
okay I'm slightly confused there um but
there clearly is a separate notion of
well walk me through what those notions
would be I mean things like okay we are
currently must care about what's the
instantaneous velocity as magnitude and
what's the current change of height
these are the two things we have as
active data okay by instantaneous
velocity you mean the vector no the
magnitude the only do you have it as air
speed that's not the same as the speed
relative to ground I don't know I mean
there's two things ground speed nasty I
don't know okay you only have the
magnitude we do in test the direction
but we do separately have we okay we
have this sequence of points that the
plane when the earth in approximately
rate right that's a different story
okay and we have rate of climb yes
exactly
I'm sure both of those are based on
ground I bet I'm sure in modern times I
mean in the past they were air speeds
but probably I'm sure now they're ground
speeds um okay so what's your point
there so so for every position we have
you know four so for each thing that's
very precision finite set of times we
have positions with other things okay so
we have a time stamp we have the
position we have the velocity we have
random stuff like the climb rate right
good okay and the two big equation we
probably want to do is not respect to
geo position because we don't know where
the beyond it's one dimensional pass but
with respect to time so why isn't this
just a time series with zero position
payloads
I think because if we have a function
dedicated to this it will be able to
handle the opposition sorry dear
arguments and geo properties because we
want to top it conveniently into dual
graphics and friends but so why would we
not okay so the problem is that you know
we've got date list plot okay which eats
time series right what you're saying is
we don't have a a geode eight let's plot
in a sense it would do well okay so I'm
not sure either but I mean it well
here's what it might see it might draw
up you know it might draw a picture like
the Napoleon's army picture or something
where where it is you know where it got
to at a certain time with a like a
parametric plot effectively yes think
geo this plot will do that on time
series of Geo data okay so what you're
saying geo let's plot what are you
claiming you're claiming how do I get a
time series of geo data okay time series
and we'll just build up a simple example
okay let's do now and then now plus
let's do now we're in LA and okay and
we'll see if it doesn't now plus two
weeks what would it do what entities
gee let's plot it you know may convert
it okay so then you're in New York okay
that's probably good enough for us for
right now okay so let's go geo let's
plot of that yeah so you don't get the
curve by default but it has gone in and
pulled out what happened and it also
doesn't in any way label the times right
can you try Geographics of geo path of
that time series I do remember when a
participant okay why is that geo path
straight in that projection is that just
the projection in which it is straight
yes changes the projection to Mankato
for example why did it start labeling
the state we have labels for a correct
angular and Mercator and remove them for
the other projections because they get
too curved and it looks bad right what
has happened to the deep buzzing of
Geographics project we are getting
closer to that by by using insert
instead of texture and and then the
objective is to have the labels
separately generated Yeah right not
baked on the attacks by the way
somebody's saying from the live stream I
was I was right that the compass
direction in a plane as the direction
your nose is pointed in which is not
necessarily the vector the velocity
vector but I think what we are getting
so do we get heading as in which
direction the nose is pointed or do we
get don't we get that in the enough feed
no we don't I thought we did I mean
let's see let's try random flight
no that's not very useful let's try okay
what the heck is heading what is heading
here is that deduced from the from the
interpolated points
I do not know event I'm really quite
certain that the these mode C
transponder things you know give
altitude don't know about this other
stuff here
yes altitude we have yes that's correct
right okay so so this ground speed looks
like it has enough detail in it that it
isn't coming from finite differences
okay no no no there was no statement so
that attitude I consider to be part of
current CEO position already because I'm
okay fine but we get independently we
get TC by DT as a own field okay okay
and this heading is a bit of a mystery
yeah I know but now I'm guessing that
this is absolute heading which by the
way probably should should indicate here
that's a question for the Wolfram Alpha
Team because that's a little bit
confusing given given um okay depending
on what it actually is all right okay
let's go back to this so your point here
is that we could imagine a geode eight
let's plot so we've really got two cases
here we've got the Geo value field
I'm now totally conceived what's the
difference in that into your histogram
histogram and Geo smooth histogram what
they effectively do is to derive a value
field and by default that's the
intensity field the number of events per
area
I see so but this is deriving a value
field from actual given values not from
histogram right yes so some point data
can you know it's like statistical point
data can be related to fields so I was
just giving you one such example and
they can interact the other way around
two fields can affect distributions
right but okay but so right now we don't
have let's see we don't have the we have
geo histogram but we don't have this
smooth field thing we do we don't have
the density plot what is it called geo
geo smooth histogram no but that's still
a histogram right we don't have a
density plot right and we were just
planning out that those you know those
are things that we we would like to do
next okay but so what this is asking for
is something that goes underneath geo
density plots because it is the it is it
is to geo density plot as interpolation
is to density plots kind of yes what or
to Liston City plot rather yes um
although this is really geo list density
plot isn't it not geo density plots
right right I mean for the most part
we've been letting geo employ list sorts
of things okay right because I don't
think we're going to have very many
visualization function geovisualization
functions that are actually taking a
function well unless we managed to get
PDE s over the g OV over the geoid right
and Roger can you comment on that
no I mean like for example
we can imagine something about you know
for that bit epidemiology it will be
really nice to have p d--'s directly
over geo coordinates but it would still
be a discrete thing thing a discrete
representation y know it wouldn't do it
will be like here we know more discrete
than an interpolating function its
discrete it will be saying this you know
the probability of it happens three
giving proble it's a bit let's say the
density let me give you an example let's
imagine when Mount st. Helens blew up
right there was a big plume of gunk that
stretched across the US right that plume
of gunk was given was governed
presumably roughly by PDE we can imagine
solving that PDE and asking the question
what is the instantaneous concentration
of gunk in Chicago at day such-and-such
based on Mount st. Helens yes if we
return at your value field it doesn't
matter where it came from
it's your value field and internal it
has a discrete like interpreting
function representation of the data fine
could be both the constructor and the
container yes but I mean I guess what
you're saying is that that internally to
geo value field you could imagine some
situation in which this thing was an
interpolating function that right
because that's what you would get out if
you actually solved the you know the PDE
s for Mount st. Helens or whatever you
would get an interpolating function not
a bunch of discrete values yes and if
this is stuck in some projection that
handles both XYZ that's perfectly
rational interpolating function then
would be something that is mapping
geo-positioning values right in much the
same way as geo value field does but
this is just a wrapper that says make it
a smooth interpolation but but what we
proposed is that that wouldn't be
interpolating it would be a new object
that actually understands something geo
so from a user point of view it wouldn't
be if it would right what I'm saying is
if you if you needed to do the loop the
workflow in which you go
through the PDA functions but I think
it's fine if we put inside an
interpreting function it's fun from the
outside it looks like a day of value
field we don't care what it has inside
as long as it fits it eats your
positions and returns values oh I see
what you guys are saying I think what
you'd want to do is to put rappers
before and after right it has like all
deal okay yeah so there's a trio
position inside this thing and it could
have any coordinates which are in some
projection or some map projections and
then we don't even need to do positions
but the Geo value field we would worry
about all of that right interpolation
seeing function but wouldn't care about
what the meaning of kids coordinates
okay so chill value field seems like a
sensible thing and that would allow us
to I mean that's solving a completely
different problem from the airplane
problem yes the problem with the
airplane planner problem is the
embedding the embedding of a line in
three-dimensional space and of course we
could be very mathematical here and
repair this for embeddings but that's
going to be very difficult so that's why
I prefer to have a dedicated geo
trajectory oh yeah so this relate to
travel directions don't we already have
something very much like this I mean if
we have if I say travel directions so
directions can be done at geo path or
let's say travel directions how does it
work from from New York City to Boston
let's say um okay so now if I say geo
Geographics if I say geo list lots of
that oh that's weird why doesn't that
work
dude you gotta fix a video path of that
I think that that thing I just did
should work I don't see why it shouldn't
work journalist blot of that well it has
very very many points
so so this is more like a line rather
than 10-point point based okay so this
is exactly so for example one thing
we're not doing here is marking the
times you know when do I get to
Bridgeport right for example yeah so
that would be an example of a place
where just like the plain case or the
case I mean we need a way to show
essentially a geode eight let's plot in
which we have a line but the line has
been parameters and we look we go either
way around but clearly on a map yeah I
mean geo dateless plot is what we're
gonna need for this so can you change
your path to point inside Geographics
just the word point yes okay
develop bonds there's everything so
what's your point so to speak well that
the list plot typically plots a few
points of main location so some say that
I don't think that's come on it'd be
like saying chill let's plot plots only
a few points I mean we should be able to
scale up the number of points I'm
talking about speed I'm talking about
the main purpose of the function I don't
see you're saying I don't see why
there's a problem in it plotting more
points but I mean but but your point
here is I mean clearly this is sort of
the inverse of well these points have no
relationship to when it when you will
reach you know Hartford for example
right right it's not like they're every
five minutes or anything right but so
the correct I mean the correct
visualization for that is you have a
line and you have essentially mesh
points on that line that represent the
times I think or maybe you have a little
tick mark across
that seems like well that seems like one
useful visualization another
visualization as you might show the
vector direction of the you know the the
direction that knows that the plane is
pointing at every position there which
isn't just you know tangent to the
trajectory but these points are there
for every single change of direction and
if you do this with dynamic Geographics
and assuming a thing is going to become
clear
so you're saying dynamic dynamic
Geographics now assuming to some points
doesn't this let me help
[Music]
why is it not that's a bug that is why
is that not okay
hey this is eleven three prototype build
so I didn't no idea what it is I'll take
a look at it after in the meaning okay
so when I'm going around that corner
there I've got a bunch of extra points
so those are those points are at the the
that road is represented in osm as a
bunch of line segments that right yes so
this is approximating that data okay
okay so that's one thing that's in a
sense if we did a geode a twist plot I
mean it's it's really a Geo time plot of
some kind I mean I think it's the analog
the Geo analogue of a parametric plot it
seems to me and you might want to
highlight some things label some things
how do you in a parametric plot how do
you do you mash go ahead well
don't have labeling there at this point
but you can certainly yes you can
certainly show the mesh that you've been
using right every five minutes or
whatever else it is right right which
will be which will be a good start here
it will be even better if you could mark
you know 3:00 p.m. 4:30 p.m. and so on
you need to know your cert time some
weight well if you have G oh yes right
but well all you need to just have
relative times one hour one and a half
hours etc right all right let's let's
zoom out and we have to wrap up here um
so what we're concluding is I mean this
meeting went in a very different
direction than I expected
the it sounds to me like geo value field
is something that is in our path so to
speak no don't we also need so I'm a
little bit confused if we have a geo
path don't we need the analog of geo
value field for telling us this
parameterised time you will be at this
point on the geo path right no words if
I say where was that plane at 11:17 p.m.
that's kind of one of the main things we
need from this function yeah yes sorry I
suggested your trajectory for that not
not having geo path being responsible
for doing that no I understand but I
mean what you're saying is what you are
then implying is that geo trajectory
which is where okay so you're saying
there's a geo trajectory which contains
which has both which has various
different attributes it has the times
the positions may or may not have extra
annotations like velocities good okay
and you're saying you're suggesting
however this is set up that there's an
access or here that allows you to ask
for an absolute time right and get out a
result
exactly and also that geo trajectory
when displayed in a Geographics would
display in some way that marks its time
points exactly it would be an implied do
path with some additional information
that we may get so let me give you an
example of an issue that isn't there an
issue of essentially a plot range for
the geo trajectory then shown really
show me only where the geo trajectory
went on Saturday right so we're going to
want to have or we're gonna have to have
a slicing function
you know windowing function show me only
the Saturday part well but I think this
from the point of view graphics this
represents a do path so this dish would
be treated in terms of plot range
osteopath
right but the plot range is is in the
Geo space as opposed to in the time
space so to speak except so this other
day geo trajectory of a time range could
it will a to achieve trajectory good
point excess point good point so this
would be a date interval here and that
would be the solution to that problem
yeah okay
so I think this is this makes a lot of
sense this function geo trajectory now
what would its detailed arguments be
would it be essentially I mean
ultimately it's got to be I mean it
could be purely geo positions with I
mean I think that's a little bit
grotesque with X Y Z T that will be one
way to do it but presumably we have to
support a different form as well which
is more of the form T arrow geo position
the steer position have time in it it
does yep really yeah
yeah I mean that we were just showing
that at the beginning of the meeting if
we say what's the Geo position of the
International Space Station
it contains the time well the name
doesn't give any hint of that you don't
say I mean because the the datums also
have time references associated with
them yes datum that that's you know like
nobody knows what datum is unless you
know what it is it's known well by the
people that knows it well
so to speak yes it's well known by
people that knows it well that's what I
am I said I didn't add this it was there
from from the beginning in version 7
this time thing yes I think we needed it
right for the datum stuff we needed it
for correct geodesy um ok ok so let's go
back here to the the geo trajectory
stuff so what we would do so I assume
that time series supports T arrow type
stuff as well does it
we're not done yes okay so I mean we
should support whatever time series
supports in terms of the way to relate
times to payloads mm-hmm yeah we're
gonna be very flexible in England and
then yeah it will convert to our
canonical form all right so look I think
the answer to what does the plane give
is the plane what does the you know
where does the plane go as the plane
goes on a geo trajectory is that a
satisfactory answer for you Michael I
think so give me a little bit
discouraged for the shape of X 6 X's I
didn't know I was imagining that that
well whatever time series does this
should do so I'm just suggesting that X
X X here is would check time series has
this one feature which is not so nice
that all the data have to be rectangular
so here I would say T goes to up at your
position or a list of things your
position
and your vector field for its section in
principle if if Wolfram language support
an abstract vector space that could work
there well you're asking can you do this
with a non I don't know how we would
render that graphically I mean with
respect to the access or you know with
respect to this access or we can
certainly deal with that knowledge how
we interpolate those things I think we
miss on the sense little bit like
obviously X X X is kinda a repetition of
what about the first one is but we
haven't yet folded in the auxiliary
information you mean the velocities yes
we have would it be and how well I'm
imagining but I might be wrong that it's
on the right-hand side here of the t
arrow thing it's your position along
with the GL position yes that it could
be not just a naked geo position but you
know that's the kind of thing that you
can do for a function like this because
you can you can sort of enumerate what
are the things that can be there that
are useful and then it does you know it
does very few operations generally
speaking yeah but it's completely
obvious what that's gonna do look if I
gave to geo positions if I go T arrow
you know pair to your position to your
position what on earth is that gonna do
well the first one is considered the
position at which it is the second one
is curvature information which could be
fine to say that I think that's a good
start
I mean I think we might get more
sophisticated and the T arrow thing
might be able to be an association where
we could give a a preferred key like
location or something as the actual
position and then the other stuff is
other parts of the payload I mean I can
see all kinds of issues like do we
interpolate the other elements of that
you know when you do an access or at t1
do you interpolate the other elements of
that payload or not see what I'm saying
yes so the D certainly needs an
interpolation order but does it need an
interpolation order for all the
different pieces because you might want
a different relation order the you know
to toot from the pure position I think
that's a level of complexity I mean you
have to fill in all data like time
serious exists or no I understand
rectangularity yeah I understand the I
don't know I mean I think what do we
have that is I mean this is like what
would exist in like a machine learning
function or some other place where we
are giving you know where we're
specifying what here I mean we're you
know in the machine learning functions
right there is a not complete insistence
on rectangularity although the things
that you know that then then there are
all these net encoders and things which
turn whatever data is given into some
kind of canonical conforming form let's
try to not address this issue right now
I mean what we have to deal with right
now is geo trajectories we can we
finally get the you know the voyages of
Captain Cook which I think was one of
the you know I think it's in the data
repository that you know where he went
at what time you know ending up wherever
he ended up Tahiti or wherever it was um
and um you know where we should be able
to plot that showing you know with a
trajectory showing marks showing when we
when we you know labeled I guess what
that is something we don't have yet for
mesh for you know mesh points in
graphics which is labeled mesh point and
here we might imagine that we I guess
here we could we should be able to have
a label how would we do that
I don't know we'd probably want some
kind of label thing I think we ran out
of time here we've got a direction here
I think this is going to work for the
flight you know to know roughly what we
returned from the flight data stuff um
anything else we need to cover
essentially here oh okay
stuff and two people on the live stream
see you later
and everybody meetings see you later